he must have given up thrown in the
towel abandoned his sad little
masquerade
I finally got to him the power of the
press triumphs very rarely do I actually
see these big blockbuster movies when
they're in theaters and I did see this
one and I hate to be so predictable but
I have to tell you that I I didn't like
the movie
[Applause]
it seems like everyone loves it it's got
like 105 percent of Rotten Tomatoes
everyone loves the movie
[Applause]
for me the the Spider-Man movie
exemplifies everything that's wrong with
superhero movies Spider-Man and first of
all just to run through some of the
problems there are no Stakes okay I
don't mean s-t-e-a-k-s
um there's nothing at stake okay there's
no there's no there's not a whiff of
suspense or narrative tension with these
movies because every problem is solved
with either miraculous technology or
superpowers and okay that part I get
it's a superhero movie or or literal
magic now Magic's real here too I mean
no no it's not real it's been a while
since I've seen one of these and now
apparently now in the in the Marvel
superhero Universe they have actual
Wizards who can just who can just fly in
and snap their fingers and make
everything okay
so there's no limits there's no rules
within the universe itself and then and
then so it's like watching someone play
a video game with all the cheat codes
there's no suspense to it there's
there's no point in watching it I'm I'm
fine obviously with uh the idea of a
superhero movie or a science fiction
movie where things can happen in that
world that can't happen in reality that
makes sense it's fiction but what you
have to do and this is just good writing
you set the rules for this universe in
the beginning and the rules can be
completely different from the rules in
our universe that's fine but then you
have to obey those rules within the
story rules are meant to be broken
instead in this movie you know you could
have a super villain from a previous
film and uh you know he he took up
multiple films he was a big bad guy in
previous films and in this one he was
like Turned good with a contraption that
a kid whips together in a lab at a scrap
metal in three minutes they never
explain how he did it but okay well you
could do that now and if that doesn't
work a wizard can fly in and brainwash
the world
then there are multiverses and Time Warp
so you can go back in time and forward a
Time figure it out
time travel all of that can be utilized
if the narrative requires if the writers
write themselves into a you know write
their backs against the wall and they
need to get out of a of a tough pinch
well you know just go to a different
Universe bring a wizard in whatever
whatever you have to do and then you
have like a superhero can stop a train
or something with one hand in one scene
but then in the next it could be knocked
unconscious with a simple Punch To The
Head see the rules are Rewritten
depending on what the writers need for
each scene and it's lazy and boring it's
fun for the kids but it's bad filmmaking
president Trump recently issued a
warning from his Mar-A-Lago home quote
our currency is crashing and will soon
no longer be the world standard which
will be our greatest defeat frankly in
200 years there are three reasons the
central banks are dumping the US dollar
inflation deficit spending and our
insurmountable national debt the fact is
there is one asset that has withstood
famine Wars political and economic
upheaval dating all the way back to
Biblical times and that is gold I've
bought gold from Birch gold in
preparation for uncertain Economic Times
and you can trust them too can now own
gold in a tax sheltered retirement
account with the help of Birch gold
that's right Birch gold will help you
convert an existing Ira or 401K into an
IRA in Gold the best part is you don't
pay a penny out of pocket the currency's
fail gold is a safe haven how much more
time does the Dollar have you can
protect your savings with gold Birch
gold as an A plus rating with the Better
Business Bureau they have thousands of
happy customers I'm one of them if you
want to be one of them you can text
Walsh to 989-898 to get your free info
kit on gold again text Walsh to
989898 today three days later you know
over the last couple days I've spoken
about my experience watching the latest
Spider-Man film
um I didn't like it to say the least and
during the comment section of the show I
have briefly made my case against it
this conversation has provoked Anger
from the audience and even dissension
within the ranks at the daily wire here
is my overall rating second best
Spider-Man film of all time after into
the spider-verse and I'm told by a
source that when I was making fun of
Spider-Man yesterday on the show the
people in the control room
were shaking their heads scornfully
because they didn't approve of what I
was saying
one thing you know about me is that when
people get upset about something that I
say
that just encourages me to say it again
louder and longer
I have as you know the maturity of a
four-year-old which means that I should
actually be the target audience for
Marvel movies but they still don't
resonate with me because although I have
the maturity of a toddler I still have
the brain of an adult which
unfortunately precludes me from enjoying
anything that Marvel has to offer and so
today we're moving beyond just the
latest Spider-Man movie and instead
we're going to expand the scope of our
inquiry and finally once and for all
cancel Marvel itself all Marvel movies
they're all canceled indeed all
superhero movies of all types are
canceled
the first problem with superhero movies
is that they're all exactly the same
and they exist primarily to sell
merchandise introducing action command
Spiderman now superhero movies in the
90s were merely light on plot superhero
movies these days are entirely plot less
hey watch your mouth that's because of
the Advent of franchise filmmaking and
World building and that's turned every
movie into a setup for the next movie
nothing can ever really happen there
could be no substantial progress no
final resolution because it's always
just setting it up for the next one each
installment none of these installments
exist on their own none of them stand on
the road they just exist because they
got to set up the next one and the next
one and the next one now don't get me
wrong I don't hate superhero movies as a
concept I have nothing against a
fanciful tale about a man in a rubber
suit fighting bad guys bad guys who
threw approximately 20 million story
arcs still have not thought to simply
walk up to their Nemesis and shoot him
directly in the face now I'm no expert
on the mythology of Marvel DC but I'm
pretty sure a bullet to the face would
dispatch almost all of the heroes in all
of the universes it kind of tickles I
know except for Superman and a few
others but the rest I mean Spider-Man
just walk up to him and shoot him in the
head
but these are issues with story
and superhero movies don't exist to tell
stories they exist to perpetuate a brand
now when I talk about this I'm often
accused of of taking the stories too
seriously but that's exactly the problem
I don't take them seriously because I
can't I take them as seriously as I take
like a Geico commercial if you have a
secret identity you need to keep it
secret and the problem is that the
writers don't take the story seriously
either which is why they're at the point
now of throwing everything into the mix
just to keep the franchise going
superpowers magic miraculous technology
throw it all in whatever is needed in
each successive moment to propel it to
the next moment and then at the end you
can erase everybody's memory and uh and
do it all over again in the next movie
all of these Marvel scripts they should
be writing listicles for BuzzFeed but
instead they're making Marvel movies
because that's what the movies really
are they're kind of just like click bait
content it's uh it's Marvel saying well
here's more here's two he's two and a
half hours you sit down and and
have some of this that's why I don't
just dislike these movies I reject them
on principle I hate everything they
stand for and I urge you to Free
Yourself of their clutches
I urge you to join me in saying to comic
book movies
you are canceled I am inevitable